so here look at inside for Washington
shot clock is winding down
grant will hoist from anywhere including
their long 3/4 Devante grant and
Charlotte gets a reload he just pulled
of DeAndre because I'm not sure we've
seen beyond race for as much as he
smiles Graham another stories coming
with Jared Allen it doesn't seem to
matter they're having a tough time
stopping it and there be a poem has to
make a tough this exact moves like
Graham Bridget knocked away by Pinson
Bayamo looking for some help the cut by
Graham and the floater goes the teen
point advantage for Brooklyn
Graham protects and scores from the left
hand he knows that Jaron Helen 66-53
Brooklyn Graham's jump shot goes temple
off the back of the iron Harris got a
hand on it bridges whips it ahead Graham
couldn't slam it but he lays it in lost
for a moment by Zeller
Graham handles it with seven to shoot
and fires a three
Devonte Graham locked and loaded Zeller
with the board Graham pedal to the medal
grama three always feeling it 20-point
games one is rookie season three last
season early 24 games into the season
burden tonight is already Allen's fourth
20-point game of the year another stat
to illustrate how
[ __ ] fadeaway well short from Torian
Prince Prince goes down Graham cut necks
it's a three Harris draws the assignment
on grant tend to shoot under a minute to
play
grant jumper he's lethal
Devonte Graham with a setback as he got
a toe on the line but nonetheless watch
where Garrett temple is that hands up
the quickness of Graham to be able to 37
program 24 in the second half shot clock
is down to three Graham let's draw a
crab is not human up with Devonte Graham
and doing his best to do so but Graham
the step to shoot he doesn't need a
whole lot of airspace and second-year
player has just been speck